hello everyone and welcome to EU people
will receive today margarita Skinner's
chief spokesperson of the European
Commission we will talk about some of
the main topics that we have seen a
spread online but especially about
himself we will even play some games so
we can meet the person behind the suit
to enjoy relaxed this is new people
you
here is Margherita Skinner's Greek from
Thessaloniki 55 years old and a live
dedicated today you some people here in
the corridor call him terminator and he
doesn't like to be called a you regret
so Marguerite is welcome alright this
are you are you a you regret no I'm not
a uric rat I'm European civil servant I
hate the word bureaucrat because it has
the Greek root kratos in it which means
power i don't conceive our job in terms
of power I prefer the notion of service
it suits us more ok how did you end up
here how did you become spokesperson of
the European Commission because it's not
something that you dream about when
you're a kid no but when Greece joined
the European communities I was about to
enter university so I felt that this was
the call of my generation I'm a believer
I didn't come for their salary i from
the very start I thought that this is a
generational call for someone my age so
I in a way prepared my way to Brussels
and I'm delighted that it works out well
ok and what we're doing what you're not
wearing a tie because I was expecting
you even today not wearing a tie but I
can see you I mean I am pretty sure that
I have never seen you without the tie ok
let's know I often do not wear a tie but
I think that when I come in the
Commission as the visible face if you
like in the voice of the Commission I
owe it a bit to do the image of the
institution to wear a tie but I can
assure you that I am also an on type
person I can become one in life and you
mentioned it well you have been the boys
in a way of the of the institution for
for some years already and you have been
facing journalists in a way answering
their questions every day in the press
room has been any of those that you kind
of remember
like saying I just want to get out of
here no no I never I never had the sense
of taking me out of here each day is
different in a way this is the beauty of
this job that you can never plan enough
because we live in a in an age where the
new cycle is 24/7 and even if you
prepare as much as you can and as best
as you can
reality very often does not align with
your planning so I enjoyed every single
moment well the good ones and the bad
ones what about your family when they
see you in television they you know
point out mistakes or they tough on you
or no they don't they don't my family
here in Brussels I think they're very
understanding of how the difficulties of
this job so they don't sort of bring it
at home my parents back home
they seem to be more interested in the
way I look rather than what what I say
which is understandable from the parents
point of view and actually before going
to the to the press room you will have
everyday meeting or a breakfast dying
with the president can you tell us
something that we don't know about it
how these conversations develop well the
president who is I think by now very
known to our staff is a nice person he's
a good guy he has empathy he listens and
he is one of the few politicians at
least I know that would ask you about
your family your parents your children
he has he takes a personal interest in
people which is an asset an asset for
the top person in a huge administration
like ours it is important that the lead
figure is a person who listens and and
and who can act beyond the traditional
boundaries of a politician Yoga is
nice guy take it from me and and because
it's not only the present of course you
have metal also lots of prime minister
tell me one or two that you have you
know you have been impressed with you
know well impress this to be too big a
word for this thing but i think i i i
have met recently i will tell you one
from our from from within and one from
outside the European Union I have met
recently Alexander usage which is who is
the Serbian president he was the
youngest MEP the youngest minister the
youngest Prime Minister now the youngest
president of Serbia ever he is a very
interesting person with a very clear
sense of European perspective for his
country he has the vision to take Serbia
closer to Europe but he's also bit like
younger someone with empathy he would
make you feel comfortable he will take
an interest in you he will share with
you his thoughts so and from within
Emmanuel macron I think is is also one
of the kind I had a chance to together
with President Juncker to to see him
recently and travel with him on a
certain missions he also not only of
course he's a true believer in Europe
and in the value of European aggression
but I also like in him that he finds a
way to make each one of the people
around him feel important that's also an
asset for a politician he would
hesitation or comment on everybody he
turned to me and said are you still
doing a media briefing okay and you
answered yes yes unfortunately it's
going to be like legacy of this younger
Commission saving grace keeping the euro
and the eurozone strong and United
materializing an ambitious investment
program of enormous scale that was
missing from our economic political mix
the intelligent
application of the stability and growth
pact that brought all our economies back
to growth and to record high employment
and the first meaningful attempts to
create a true holistic EU my Gration
policy these will be the legacy elements
of this commission I think any kind of
skills that the next president of the
Commission should have yes I think three
mainly first he has to be a believer he
has to be live in Europe otherwise this
job cannot be done the second I would
say has to be a awesome blur it has to
be he or she has to be someone able to
rally around him or her a broader
majority I don't think that the
Commission can be partisan and the third
quality of the future president would be
we would look for a person with a
certain physical resistance because
people traveling all the time shuttling
around it's not something easy so I are
the three conditions okay okay let's see
interesting so now that we that we have
been able to meet you a bit a bit closer
a bit more let's go to the political
arena everything going to to ask you a
bunch of questions okay that you will
have to answer yes or no and it's going
to be in 59 seconds okay let's play
[Music]
so we starting in 3 2 1
that's breaks it means breaks it yes is
they you a safer place to live in than
four years ago yes will they you
implement the Paris agreement no matter
what
yes it's Merkel dictating the present
and future of the you know are there any
political prisoner in the European Union
no is there you doing enough regarding
migration no is there you banning kebabs
certainly not
that's the Commission wants to build a
you super state no will the European use
by all Member States eventually yes it's
social media damage in democracy no are
we in a trade war no is the future of
Europe more Europe that's a difficult
one
[Music]
I'm going to show you some pictures of
people that I I'm sure that you know for
you to come in so first thing that comes
through your mind you can say it
no no risk no no fear so we can we can
directly go with the first one
mrs. Merkel I would say an anchor of
stability resume an honest politician
trying to do its be her best out of a
difficult situation mr. Vladimir Putin
I strongly there but not the Western
leader Donald Trump the Western leader
but not a strong leader mr. Erdogan
enable but a difficult one salvini
democracy is always right
mr. Makran array of hope president
Juncker the last European standing
Carstairs
someone who made all Greeks proud I was
the man who scored in this unforgettable
final of the Euro against Portuguese
you're you're you you love football yeah
now and I was in this in this game okay
okay so the golden years of Far East the
Saloniki are in front of them or has
passed already people who know me and
know my passion for Aris Thessaloniki
they always teasing me saying that I am
deaf on sell the cause perdu defender of
lost causes but know the good years are
coming and for the you same thing okay
you are eager it is thank you very much
as me a pleasure and thank you thank you
everyone for watching
so now it is a matter of share in the
video follow us on Twitter Facebook
linen everywhere Instagram subscribe to
our YouTube channel and well we'll see
you around in the meantime stay tuned
because we will have a next gas soon
[Music]